i am georgia
I am a woman
I am a mother
I am Italian I am Christian
can't take it away
identity is precisely
the issue at the heart of our commitment
shared and the main foundation
of the confrontation of our time
identity
is the main enemy of the globalist current
and all of us who defend it
on the goal of the passionaires of progressivism
the person is being attacked
and with it the very value of human life
because each of us has a genetic code
unique and unrepeatable
that with or without pleasure is sacred
sexual identity is being attacked
that the pressure groups the gbt
wish to combat gender propaganda
in schools
in the media in the institutions
with the principle of selfie say I am not what I am
I am that I feel
I am what I am what I feel
the meaning of sacred and Christian roots
are being attacked
in the name of absolute relativism
and aggressive atheism
that ultimately
pave the way
for fundamentalist prosetiritism
our history is under attack
censored by the sculpture of the cancellation
of the left
that forget everything and destroy everything
our freedom of expression is under attack
censored every day in real life
in the media
on social networks
by the dictatorship of political correctness
in the hands of silicon valley oligarchs
that with its billionaires
digital status you impose your standards on everyone
depriving people of their wealth and sovereignty
which is financed by large financial speculation
that must break it down
to make it weak and to derive them
our entire identity is under attack
but we will not allow it
i am georgia
I am a woman
I am a mother
I am Italian I am Christian
can't take it away
they will not take it away from me
darkness is under attack